This website gets between 2,000 and
3,000 active users per day. And in
today's video, I'll be showing you a
Claude automation you can set up and
automate getting new users to your
website every single day. Let's go ahead
and get started. The first thing that
you want to do is download Claude onto
your desktop because it allows you to
use the cold work mode. Once you're in
the cold work mode, head over to
schedule and then we're going to create
a task that's going to happen daily on
your website. So, this is the task in
which I've already went ahead and
created. I told Claude to search daily
popular articles using Google News MCP
and then do your own research on the
topics and find the best topic to write
about specific for my niche and then I
want you to send the article. Once you
found the article, send it over to Word
Rocket based upon the information that
you found, write the article and then
post the article directly over to my
website. So, again, we can see here that
this is scheduled in for every single
day at 9:00 a.m. So, today
it went ahead and it ran that task at
9:00 a.m. And it found the article
Meta's AI-driven layoffs of 2026. It's a
massive breaking story
that most news articles haven't even
started to write about. So, this is how
you can hack your way into writing
new up-to-date content autopilot without
you having to actually do any research
and this is completely hands-off. If you
would like to get access to this full
prompt and workflow, comment SEO below
and I'll send it over to you. But of
course, you would customize this and
tell uh the AI within your prompting
what your niche is, what you do so that
the content is going to be specific for
your audience and for your niche. So, it
found the article, it went ahead and
used the Word Rocket MCP integration.
So, essentially, I've connected Word
Rocket over to Claude. It's also then
was able to pull the sites that I have
connected, pull my brand voice, and pull
my site maps from Word Rocket, generate
the article. We can see that the article
was generated. If I go ahead and click
into this article, I can see the title,
I can see our first cover image, second
image, so on and so forth.
And then if we go back over to Claude,
we can see again this was the same
article generated. It's a breaking news
published just hours ago, 72,000 plus
search results and surging interest.
It's a perfect fit for your specific
audience. So again, think about how
powerful this is. Every single day will
go out, find new fresh information that
Google loves, write on that topic, and
that's an easy way for you to hack and
get new um articles
written over to your website. This is
published as a draft onto my test
website and as you we can see here, the
article was actually went ahead and it's
posted onto our website here. So, just
to show you guys how we were able to
connect Word Rocket over to Claude, if I
head over to settings, then over to
connectors, and I go to custom
connector, all I need to do is copy over
this URL, so wordrocketai.com,
give it a name, and click add. Now, if I
have Word Rocket, I must have a lifetime
agency plan or a premium $20 per month
membership in order to get access to the
MCP and API. Once I have access, as you
can see here, here is a list of things
in which you can do with Word Rocket.
Now, the other MCP in which I used was
the Google News MCP. Now, I used
a website called mcp360.ai.
If I again go over to that website, I
will be able to sign in
and once I log in, as you can see,
they're going to have a variety of
different MCPs in which you can use. So,
we used the Google News Tools MCP
because it's going to pull all of the
news that it's most relevant and popular
and then it's going to
let Claude do its own research and then
send it over to Word Rocket. So, those
are the three MCPs and that MCP's
actually free to use. Uh if you start
using a lot, then you may need to get
one of their uh light plans, but you
don't you can start for completely free.
You can see I've been using it on a
daily basis and because it's a very
light um a light call, you don't need to
upgrade to pro. I still have the free
account, but it's only $16 per month if
you want to go ahead and use it. But
that is the setup and as you can see
here, this is totally automated and you
can generate your content and post it
directly over to your website. Again, if
you want to get access to this workflow,
just comment SEO down below and I'll
send it guys uh
and I'll send it over to you. If you
want to try out Word Rocket for
yourselves, head over to
app.wordrocket.ai.
Thank you and I'll see you in the next
video.